These are the correct answers, great work if you found those two. For the first
one, we want to start by multiplying our numbers together, and our variables
together. We'll have 20 times 2, which equals 40, x to the 5th times x squared
which x to the 7th. The y squared times y to the 4th, which y to the 6th. Since
under a cube root, we want to find factors that appear three times. We can
split up 40 into 8 times 5 since the cubed root of 8 equals 2. We have to leave
the 5 inside of our cube root since this factor doesn't appear 3 times. It's
not a perfect cube. Finally we deal with our variables by using power divided
by root. 7 divided by 3 is 2 remainder 1, so we'll have x squared on the
outside and x to the 1 on the inside. The cubed root of y to the 6th, is just 6
divided by 3, so y squared comes out. This gives us our final result, I hope
you found it. For the second one, we want to start by distributing 3 root 2 to
each of these radical terms. Pull out 3 root 2 times root 18, and 3 root 2
times negative 2 root 6. For the first term we'll multiply these two radicals
together to get 3 root 36. For our second term, we'll multiply 3 times negative
2, which equals negative 6, and root 2 times 6, which equals root 12. The
square root of 36 equals 6, and then we can break down the square root of 12
into the square root of 4 times 3. We simplify further, by multiplying 3 times
6, which is 18, and then we take the square root of 4, which is 2. We multiply
these two numbers together to give us our final answer, 18 minus 12 root 3.
Nice work if you found that one as well.